Moi,
en première année de Prépa HEC,
j’étais au fond de la classe,
en culture générale.
J’étais très calme :
je ne faisais pas le bordel,
je ne disais pas un mot.
J’étais TRÈS CONCENTRÉ
parce que…
je faisais des maths !
La première année de Prépa HEC,
je la connais bien,
parce que je suis passé par là
— il y a maintenant
plus de dix ans —
mais surtout parce que
ça fait aussi plus de dix ans
que je prépare des élèves de Prépa HEC
aux épreuves de culture générale
des concours des écoles de commerce.
Chaque année,
plusieurs milliers d’élèves de Prépa
HEC
s’inscrivent sur 1000 idées de culture
générale
— et beaucoup m’écrivent,
donc je connais bien leurs problèmes,
leurs défis,
ce qui marche
et ce qui ne marche pas
pour eux.
Une chose qu’ils font
PARTICULIÈREMENT MAL,
c’est identifier
LEURS OBJECTIFS.
Si vous êtes en première année
de Prépa HEC,
quels doivent être vos objectifs
en culture générale ?
Pour faire simple,
je vous conseille d’en viser
seulement DEUX.
PREMIER objectif :
que vos notes en culture générale
vous permettent de passer
en deuxième année ;
et SECOND objectif :
améliorer votre compétence
dans les différentes épreuves de culture
générale
des concours,
en vue de l’année prochaine.
Vous le savez certainement déjà,
mais une compétence CRUCIALE
en culture générale,
c’est LA MÉTHODOLOGIE
de la dissertation.
Eh bien,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut !
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Comme c’est un cours par e-mail,
vous pourrez le découvrir après la vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Je retourne à nos moutons.
Je vais vous révéler les TROIS CLÉS
pour travailler EFFICACEMENT
la culture générale en première année
de Prépa HEC.
Regardez ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo,
et vous atteindrez vos deux objectifs
en économisant beaucoup de temps.
Je me souviens qu’en première année,
le prof a passé 90 %
du temps
à débiter son cours.
C’était long,
digressif,
confus
— au point que les élèves
se sont révoltés
DEUX FOIS
au cours de l’année.
Quel est le problème
avec cette manière de faire ?
On peut dire
qu’il y a plusieurs problèmes,
mais le problème principal,
c’est L’EXCÈS
d’information.
À quoi est-ce que
ça peut bien vous servir,
un cours de TROIS CENT
pages ?
Vous allez l’apprendre
COMMENT ?
Vous n’aurez jamais le temps
de l’apprendre !
Et même si vous arrivez
à l’apprendre entièrement,
vous serez handicapés
pour les épreuves de dissertation,
parce que vous aurez
TROP D’INFORMATION
à traiter
dans un court laps de temps.
Vous avez déjà utilisé
un disque dur qui est plein à craquer ?
Eh bien c’est pareil :
vous avez beaucoup d’information,
mais vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
toute cette information,
parce que le disque dur rame.
Voici donc la solution :
vous devez LIMITER
la quantité d’information à assimiler.
Ça ne sert à rien de noter
tout ce que dit le prof,
puisque vous n’aurez
même pas le temps
de tout relire !
Non,
vous devez simplement
noter L’ESSENTIEL ;
le noter dans un format
FACILE
à relire ;
et puis le relire
RÉGULIÈREMENT.
J’ai TROIS CONSEILS
pratiques
à vous donner.
Premièrement,
notez maximum UN RECTO
par cours
— vous verrez qu’à la fin de l’année,
ça fera déjà beaucoup.
Deuxièmement,
notez EXCLUSIVEMENT
sous forme de bullet points,
élément d’information
par élément d’information.
Ça va vous forcer
à CLARIFIER
l’information,
donc vos notes seront
plus faciles à relire.
TROISIÈME
et dernier conseil :
prenez trente minutes
à une heure par semaine
pour relire ATTENTIVEMENT
vos notes.
Plutôt que de réviser toute la nuit
avant le DS,
relisez l’essentiel
au moins une fois par semaine
— ça sera suffisant.
Ça y est :
j’en ai terminé
avec la PREMIÈRE CLÉ.
On passe à la deuxième !
Je l’ai déjà dit dans d’autres vidéos
:
ce n’est pas en Prépa HEC
que j’ai appris
à faire une dissertation.
Notre prof ne nous a pas expliqué,
encore moins montré,
comment faire une dissertation.
Du coup,
quel est le problème ?
Eh bien,
plein d’élèves de Prépa HEC
— je pense même
LA GRANDE
majorité —
finissent la première année
SANS MAÎTRISER
la méthodologie de la dissertation !
Et je vous l’ai dit :
c’était aussi mon cas !
Quelle est la solution ?
À l’époque où j’étais en Prépa HEC,
en 2005,
il n’y en avait pas.
MAIS MAINTENANT,
vous pouvez vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours SIMPLE
et PRATIQUE
pour gagner des points RAPIDEMENT,
et des dizaines de milliers d’élèves
l’ont déjà suivi.
Inscrivez-vous
si ce n’est pas déjà fait,
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Alors,
vous l’avez peut-être déjà reçu,
donc je vais vous donner
DEUX CONSEILS
supplémentaires.
PREMIER conseil :
une fois que vous aurez assimilé
mon cours de méthodologie,
entraînez-vous en traitant
UN MAXIMUM
de sujets.
Isolez-vous ;
coupez les distractions,
et prenez une heure
une heure et demi
pour traiter un sujet
et élaborer le plan détaillé.
Si vous le faites
une ou deux fois par semaine,
vous allez devenir TRÈS FORT
en dissertation.
SECOND conseil :
faites corriger vos plans détaillés.
Je pense que votre prof acceptera,
mais vous pouvez aussi demander à vos amis
de vous donner leur avis.
Et si vous êtes membres
de ma formation avancée
à la méthodologie de la dissertation,
vous savez que je corrige
TOUT
ce que vous m’envoyez.
Petite précision :
cette deuxième clé
vaut non seulement pour la dissertation,
mais aussi pour la contraction
et pour la synthèse.
L’enjeu est le même :
apprenez une méthode,
et entraînez-vous régulièrement
à la mettre en pratique.
Allez,
il est temps de passer
à la TROISIÈME
et dernière clé !
La troisième et dernière clé
concerne LES TROIS EXERCICES
de culture générale :
la dissertation,
la contraction,
et la synthèse.
Vous avez deviné ?
C’est de L’EXPRESSION ÉCRITE,
dont je vais vous parler.
Quel est le problème
avec l’expression écrite ?
Le problème,
c’est que la plupart des profs
n’en parlent MÊME PAS,
alors que c’est crucial !
L’expression écrite est cruciale
en Prépa HEC
parce que si vous écrivez MAL,
vous partez avec
UN GROS HANDICAP ;
tandis que si vous écrivez bien,
vous avez au contraire
UN AVANTAGE INJUSTE.
Et ce n’est pas vrai
UNIQUEMENT
pour les exercices de culture générale
— c’est vrai
pour TOUTES
les matières littéraires.
Vous croyez vraiment
que les correcteurs de géopolitique,
d’économie,
ou de langues
n’en ont rien à faire,
de la qualité de votre style ?
Bien sûr que non.
Bon,
une fois qu’on a pris conscience
de l’importance du style,
quelle est la solution ?
Je vous la dévoile dans une autre vidéo,
intitulée « Dissertation :
les 3 secrets pour améliorer son style ».
Je vous y explique
les caractéristiques précises
du style qui SÉDUIT
les correcteurs des concours,
et je vous révèle des techniques
et des exercices précis
POUR ACQUÉRIR
ce style séduisant.
Vous trouverez facilement la vidéo
sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Regardez-la attentivement,
et vous connaîtrez
LA TROISIÈME CLÉ
pour travailler efficacement la culture générale
en première année de Prépa HEC.
Voici,
en résumé,
LES TROIS CLÉS
pour travailler efficacement
la culture générale
en première année :
LIMITER
la quantité d’information
à ingérer
— cette première clé
concerne uniquement la dissertation,
vous l’avez compris ;
DEUXIÈME clé :
acquérir UNE MÉTHODE
et s’entraîner à la mettre en pratique
— cette deuxième clé
concerne les trois exercices
(la dissertation,
la contraction
et la synthèse) ;
TROISIÈME
et dernière clé :
améliorer
VOTRE EXPRESSION ÉCRITE.
Si vous vous concentrez
sur ces trois clés,
non seulement vous aurez de bonnes notes
en culture générale
pour passer en deuxième année,
mais EN PLUS
vous serez déjà bien préparés
pour les épreuves des concours
l’année prochaine.
Je vous l’ai déjà dit,
mais je le répète au cas où :
vous devez maîtriser
LA MÉTHODOLOGIE
de la dissertation,
donc inscrivez-vous donc
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Moi,
j’ai fait pas mal d’erreurs
en première année de Prépa HEC,
donc j’espère vraiment
que cette vidéo vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour travailler EFFICACEMENT
la culture générale
en première année de Prépa HEC.